[Music]
[Music]
how you livin how you doing what is good
are you moving left go in the house
Warren Sharpe not in the house
David Ingeborg in the house what's going
on let go where is why do you have a
beard this is a the person that sits
next to me on the show has a moustache a
moustache hole I'm glad you asked
because I did bring out my array of fake
mother yes I had these hitters is not a
bit I had no I was not in on this so we
have a few options if you're watching on
YouTube I can hold them up there's one
called the intellect which is I think
very Warren chef there's also a slur
what we can do like very much does look
the most like Warren's actual mustache
intellect looks like warrants it has a
little bit of a Batmobile vibe the
butler is just a straight-up - Wild West
would be quite nice on you the gambler I
see why it's called the gambler right
when I think of a poker movie walking
into a saloon kicking the door down he's
got the Spurs going I'll take 500 and
chips
what's a coin down yeah yeah I'll bet my
horse in your house unfortunately this
is more of a bit than an actuality
because sticky moustaches don't stick to
my beard yeah but I think we should try
the intellect real quick I mean you're
not gonna bring out not do it okay so
yeah it's gonna alright and I'll do the
gambler okay so the Warren this is not a
review to be honest I got a text from
Warren yesterday that said man I'm not
really feeling that good I'm sick right
now
I can't even talk so we couldn't even as
I try and get this mustachio gotta gaze
your fingernail at stuff so I even
talked to him on the phone last night I
had to slack with him for an hour and 45
minutes I got all of the information
from Warren sharps brain I tapped into
his head like a tree and I got the
betting info out of him like SAP
and now Warren that's pretty good
this is I am the gambler is it upside
down yes it is but that's fine oh man I
don't know and let's see yours
let's see David's let's go full on dank
u yeah I think it looks solid I it's
definitely gonna fall off within like
three or four syllables but that's fine
you look like Rick and Morty Hitler I
think it's not that as soon as I as soon
as I smouched this to my face
all these EDS are statistics just like
popped into my brain it's really amazing
yeah how do you how do you feel about
this week's games now that you have a
mustache Ewing burn I now feel like I'm
gonna hit like 64 percent of my
recommendations my models are projecting
71 I didn't even have models before I
walked in here but now I got a mustache
I think this is a phone it's full of
models all right so look warren hope you
feelin better
the thing is is I wanted to get all of
the information and Warren said to me
hey I will give you this because the
people need to hear it the 33% need to
hear it this is not gonna be a show of
Ingmar and myself telling you our
opinions and going it's square Thursday
on the left go show in burrs gonna set
us up with some of the lines some of the
money lines interesting facts that he is
found I'm happy to present with actual
objective facts of where the public
money is going or what the over-under
has shifted from that that stuff's all
interesting but in terms of like here's
my opinion don't listen to it I don't
have any who do the Loch Ness monsters
like this week this remind people the
Loch Ness monsters is a complete joke
that we have in the office it's not a
real pub it's not a real pop good but
yeah we like to choose the largest line
of the week and just say what would
happen if we put all our money down on
that money line so this week it's $5,500
to win a thousand dollars over the
Dolphins Browns at home against the
Dolphins miles caret Jobi we'll see
we're gonna get into some weighted EDS
are that we promised you from last week
that Warren has looked into so not just
looking at his baby EDS are but mainly
focusing on the last month I got a
lesson for you for sharp school and we
of course will be calling crack who I
think we're gonna lean a little heavily
heavily on today and see what he's
looking at
also when to update you last show we
talked about how road dogs are covering
the most of any of the combinations at
sixty percent last week five and four
against the spread so still winning but
there's ten instances of it this week
it's a little bit too jumbled for my
blood when you said sixty percent last
week that number definitely jumped out
at me as something that could
potentially regress to the mean that's
not necessarily a trend that's going so
you know it like that could be the sort
of thing that you say hey it's sixty
percent let's ride it or you could say
hey it's sixty percent this is gonna
regress so let's fade it yeah for me
like statistics like that are it's like
when you're riding a wave and you're
surfing and I would rather be told how
great the wave was afterwards than
looking at a way yeah I don't know if
that makes any sense but like I hope I'd
be like oh shoot yeah actually I was
betting rode dogs this whole season I
don't know it feels a little late to
jump on now Sheriff all right
sharp school the other thing that Warren
wanted to talk about was predictive
models and again what that means is you
propose a play calling situation and
what the model does is tell you what
play and result happens next so for
example we talked about running backs
that have a very long run and then the
head coach goes run him again how do
they do and me and Warren joked oh
that's the Bill O'Brien school of
coaching well he looked up Bill O'Brien
and after a Texans running back runs for
10 yards or more and Bill O'Brien runs
again with that same running back
they're averaging three yards per carry
hmm
successful one out of three times when
he uses a different running back they
are averaging 12.5 yards per carry and
having success 63 percent of the time it
just makes you looking go Texans are you
self scouting mmm-hmm this segment by
the way this sharp school is more about
spotlighting bad coaches in the NFL
we know that Kyle Shanahan adjusts like
that and Belichick and Sean Payton and
Shawn McVeigh but we also need to point
out the other coaches that are winning
despite their coaches this is DeSean not
Billy OH
so I asked Warren which coaches violate
your cardinal sin if you've ever read
sharps analyst analysis
before it's if you if you don't have
success on first and ten don't run on
second and ten and I said so who runs
the most after a first and ten in
completion the NFL average is to pass 58
yards let's try that one try to be a
star right now it's real hard he's got
so many numbers yeah but I got it so
after an incomplete pass on first and
ten right it's now second in tenth the
league typically throws 58 percent of
the time I'm just a right thing to do
it's second and ten don't run it you're
about to make it third and long it's a
lot more difficult here are the teams
that run the most on second and ten
these are the offensive coordinators
that even if they're having success it
is likely in spite of them not because
of them Detroit they run at 61 percent
of the time Minnesota they run at 69
percent of the time that's incredible
that's that jumps out at me and their
success rate on those runs is 17 percent
one at a six basically and Warren added
on that one idiots
he wrote that in I like when he
editorialize this so for me it's like
here's a team like Minnesota that is
firmly in the playoff race and we're
saying that Kirk Cousins is an MVP
candidate and Dalvin cook should be in
the running - and they're doing this by
making one of the worst decisions you
can make right the Jets on second and 10
are running 62 percent of the time they
are 15 percent successful and they're
averaging 2.7 yards per carry
RF Adam GaSe the Chargers are running at
56% of the time on second down their
runs have a success rate of 30% when
they pass in the same situation they
have a success rate of 75% what's wild
about all of these teams Detroit
Minnesota Jets and the Chargers they are
all more successful wildly with the pass
and they still continue to run
and then you look at those teams Mike
Zimmer and Minnesota they're obsessed
with the run yeah I'm at Patricia in
Detroit obsessed with the run the Jets
Adam GaSe people are going what are you
doing and the Chargers as we said time
and time again have a week and or
non-existing analytics department these
are teams that can't get out of their
own way they are winning in spite of
their coaches and you just makes you
look at it and go how could a billion
dollar organization not look on a
week-to-week basis at things they are
doing but instead warren sharp mustache
and all in a basement in virginia you
can figure it out just it blows my mind
absolutely and those are some really
great stats it's a great way to follow
the league and sort of understand what
the how the coaches are impacting the
play calling and all that stuff I'm
interested to know from Warren and maybe
he talked about this with you maybe not
maybe it's something to ask for next
week is there a golden percentage that
teams should be passing on second intent
because obviously you can't load up and
pass on second or 95% of the time you
become too predictable
so is it somewhere in that 59 to 65
percent range then that's a really good
question yeah I think that's actually an
interesting thing as you look at
percentages and you want to know what
window should you be in right and I
think the way you find that is is you go
okay what's the passing rate of the
Patriots Niners and Saints yeah so but I
imagine there's some sort of bell curve
of diminishing returns if you do it too
little up so much founded 80% of the
time right but sometimes I think that's
what Warren wants sometimes I think he
wants to do that all right so then I
said okay I have another situation I
want to out these dumb coaches yeah and
a situation that that he has found which
is really dummies is its second and
short
and Warren always says run the ball and
also by the way these kind of Statistics
I love to use this when I'm watching a
game when I'm watching Eagles Patriots
and it's second and short and the Eagles
run and they don't get it and now it's
third and short and with the statistic
that Warren found was when you run on
third and short you're successful 70% of
the time so even though you didn't get
it on second and short you should
on third because if you pass it traps
from 72-56 so when I watch the Eagles on
Sunday and I'm rooting hard against the
Seahawks and they run on second and
short and don't get it and then they
pass on third and short
that's when I get to yell are you
[ __ ] dumb and as a fan I feel really
smart right there yeah so if you throw
on third and short after running it who
are the biggest violators of this thus
far Washington does this 86% of the time
that camp that's that doesn't feel right
that's insane the Steelers do it 83% of
the time the Bears have done it 67% of
the time and here's what's wild remember
also if these are smaller sample sizes
so that this has happened to the Bears
nine times where they've had second and
short run didn't get it and then got the
third down they've passed six times
they've run it three and those three
were successful every single time but
they're still passing it twice as much
as they run it smaller sample sizes but
it's actually like that's called
situational football right that's that
there are limited amount of times in
which you get to make the right decision
and you are making a mistake well more
than you're making the right decision
and I'm very interested in the coming
years as this coaches risking it on
fourth down starts becoming more and
more of a regular thing instead of like
we look at horrible wow what a
risk-taker he's great Boyle as this
start starts happening your view of
second down play calling in your view of
third down play calling will totally
change because if you've got second in
one we now think you've got two chances
to punch it to a first down but now if
you become the John Harbaugh John
Harbaugh becomes the regular horse and
John horrible you now have three chances
of getting that first down and maybe
that changes up maybe you're you're more
likely to throw it a little bit deep on
second down or even on third and one it
is interesting in terms of like the
ability to take a risk but I know Warren
has always said that first downs and and
getting to the next town is the biggest
because I bet you there's also the
notion sure you could take a chance on
second but the percentage of completion
by running it on second and third
compared to running it on second third
and fourth I mean it might go from like
80% to 90% sure
and the fact that if you if you are
known as a coach or known as a team that
is often going to go for it on fourth
and one you completely have to shift
your defensive mindset against them on
second and one and third and one because
now all of a sudden everything is in
play on second one and third and one
what's wild to me is how many teams are
actually thinking like this well I'm
just saying this is this is a shift that
I'm excited yeah at you you and Warren
and I are all in the same page about
it's not just about saying this is gonna
happen or this is gonna happen but it's
about watching the teams play the most
efficiently and if we start to see more
and more evidence that going for it on
fourth down is a better evidential play
yes and increases your percentage of
chance of winning
then more coaches will start doing this
this will become the regular mind that's
and then the analytics will shift I also
love that as the league gets younger
it's going to happen more mm-hm and that
the people that say things like we need
to establish the run
we need to pound the rock we need you
know like if we run it twenty five times
in the game or 19 one like people that
cling to the old mine and I feel like
this has been a transitional year and I
think partially it's because of the
people that were discussing the MVP race
lamar's and Dax and and the DeShawn's
and the Russell Wilson's these were
people that were deemed by the old guard
not even quarterbacks
and I think that was the most blatant
and egregious ignorance of that
generation is their inability to look by
and then to suppress people from playing
positions and jobs yeah and now it's
going to swing so hard the other way
that that high school football coach the
coach that never punts bleacher report
did a story about him all he does is
kick onside kicks and go for a quarter
pounds guy even if it's like fourth and
10 from your own they've won like 10
state championships in a row he probably
has some talent on his team in addition
to some crazy coaching tactics I don't
know man we I'm telling you bleach
report went down there I bet he has some
talent on that team there's some talent
but also like I bet you they also
practice those situations more than any
other team thus giving you an edge like
there are even edges me and Warren laugh
about this to where Belichick never says
anything about the other team he never
talks about strategy at all but a coach
like Doug Marrone after a loss to the
Colts will come out and say we're not
running the ball with Leonard fournette
enough right and then Warren will go
what are you doing the other
coach now is going to go guys okay let's
think about the situations in which
they're typically gonna maybe go past
but they're gonna go run now we're gonna
load more guys like why would you ever
give that out and I look I wouldn't put
it past some coaches they can't put out
false information but coaches like Doug
Marrone who are fervent eaters of
bologna sandwiches are and that's a fact
they learned to be like I'm a meat and
potatoes guy I tell it like it is and if
I think Leonard foreign that's not
getting the ball enough I'm gonna say it
like it is I bet you if I googled Doug
Marrone tell it like it is I could find
seven different articles right and it's
just it's very funny to me that even
down to that there's efficiency what we
say to the media yeah and when you when
you slack back and forth with Warren for
an hour and 45 minutes you realize all
of the things he's paying attention to
and that remember when crack was in here
preseason saying that he employs
multiple readers people just read every
article because these coaches give away
their secrets I remember him saying that
during the preseason yeah guys are a lot
looser about stuff and you know like
some coach might let it slip or some
offensive coordinator but some assistant
might let it slip like yeah you know
what we're gonna give DeAndre Hopkins
the afternoon off like they might say
something like that for a preseason game
you can bet on these preseason games yes
at the same point I believe this is the
time of the year where the coaches start
to slip again hmm
number one coaches on the hot seat you
need to provide explanations you start
talking in circles you start saying
things number two coaches outperforming
expectations a little bit of ego a
little bit of confidence you start kind
of losing track there are only certain
guys that I think never give it away and
that's the camp Belichick other than
that like Doug Peterson gives away stuff
all the time right well we got to get it
to this guy more what you just said
about coaches having to provide
explanations and I understand that we're
all in job preservation mode and if
you've got a kick-ass job as the head
coach of NFL team you want to keep that
job I understand that but you have to
explain it to the media because we still
talk about things in traditional old
school terms that if you punt the ball
you quote played it safe as opposed to
if you went for it on fourth down you
quote were bold but if the evidence says
that going for it on fourth down is a
better percentage pace we should
referring to punting as the risky play
because you're taking the risk of just
handing the ball back to your opponent's
under Sun if we as the media start to
phrase it that way then these coaches
won't have to you know hangdog go up at
the at the podium and say like yeah you
know we just really sorry Karen Kendall
yeah so dad I just
we you know we punted and I feel bad we
you know we gave the ball back to
deshaun Watson and uh he scored he
scored and I feel terrible
like he should have to explain that part
I agree well that's why John Harbaugh is
rant a few weeks ago explaining it was
after the Chiefs loss about how the
reason they went for it on all the
fourth downs and all the two-point
conversions and the math that they
looked into it and a lot of people
thought he was making excuses and really
it's one of the few franchises in this
league that has done the analytical work
and has subscribed to it to a level that
even when there are days that the 20%
hits we are staying to it and the media
couldn't understand it and but I will
say this the people that I follow on
Twitter the analytics communities the
the communities that are not afraid to
break things down and it's not just all
gut there are if you are watching
broadcast television you are not
learning anything about football let me
say that again for the people in the
back if you're watching broadcast
television you are learning very little
about football there are some people
that are on the major networks and and I
think you know who they are at the four
letters and all that stuff that they do
have great things to say the problem is
is they have 45 seconds to say it and
they can't get into any depth there are
a podcast that you could listen to
that's not broadcast there are articles
you can read that's not broadcast but my
problem is is that most people watch
Sunday morning pregame shows they watch
midweek debate shows and there is no
information and I think it's keeping the
level of discourse about the NFL in 1980
mm-hmm the main analysts for certain NFL
shows include John Fox Jimmy Johnson I
gotta stop naming names is good intense
but these are people and I always say
Jimmy Johnson who's Jimmy Johnson was at
the forefront for a lot of that
the early 90s but people like John Fox
are exactly what we're talking about and
we're putting them in positions to honor
the old guard and it's it blows my mind
because there's no inherent value in
listening we know all of their
catchphrases we know them you said it
playing it safe yeah being bold you know
and there's nothing else and when you're
a non analytics follower if you're
someone that just like believes in the
maxims right then when the one time it
fails if you go for it on fourth down
and it fails they go see told you as
opposed to saying like what can we look
at the sample size of the last 75 times
this this happened and it was successful
68% of the time or sometimes I think the
fact that the NFL is a low sample size
game yes
combined with the fact that it's the
most brutal of the games and has the
most catchphrases yeah rub some dirt on
it and gridiron and all this stuff at
your finger off if you're in I think
it's like the worst combination because
it's like the people that inherently
would hate analytics the most in a game
that has the least reliable analytics
yeah it's just a weird combination
speaking of analytics that I do trust
and let's get a little bit more positive
it is Warren's baby EDS are early down
success rate last week what do you know
for in a week and if you included the
other three games that he talked about
it really was a seven in a week amazing
but I am NOT gonna count those other
three we need to keep it facts so he was
for a nose straight up three and one
against the spread
he got Buffalo over Miami he got the
Rams over Chicago and got the Browns
over the Steelers the only one it didn't
cover was the Niners over Arizona but
again Warren said on the podcast that
number was way too big so he ETS are
from the time we started counting I
think in week six
it is now 19 and five overall 13 11 and
one against the spread the 49ers they
won by 10 but he had him at 10 and a
half or something
the line was 11 okay it some places it
came down to nine and a half I know that
was a that was a disaster for Vegas that
final touchdown on the punt I think so
far I've used the West Gate line okay
for everything just to kind of keep it
as one simple thing so you're right I
guess in some ways it's still covered
that's the power of EDS our EDS are it
covers wait can I just make my pitch for
EDS are ASMR okay this is just for you
to like okay have a channel I just it
just was something that popped into my
head it's just you whispering very calm
tones about ASMR so it's like you can
learn and it's very soothing oka heading
into a very stressful gambling day on
Sunday you can just listen to EDS are
ASMR okay ETS are ASMR AMS are ASMR ASMR
yeah
it's those like those whisperings I want
everyone to go back and listen to that
last exchange in slow motion
so put your podcast at point five and
just do some more you show more okay all
right I'll do that so I have the four
biggest EDS are matchups for week 12 the
traditional one that includes all year
and then I have the four weighted which
is the last month I asked Warren I said
which one do you value more he said it
should be a blend okay so here is your
traditional EDS are mismatches for week
12 Titans over Jaguars Titans over
Jaguars yeah number two bills over
Broncos bills over Broncos I'm just
saying it up normal voice in case you're
like in the subway right now and you
can't hear the way yeah yeah 49ers 49ers
of her Packers I would have thought that
those guys were pretty similar great
play callers but okay I know it's the
third biggest that's the third biggest
mismatch
very soothing to hear someone drink
water Browns
over alpha that's the lock of the week
baby oh the Loch Ness monsters alright
so here are the he uh here are the
weighted EDS RS if you just look at the
last month only factoring the last month
number one Saints with a monster EDS our
advantage over the Panthers and they are
nine and a half point favorites so that
makes sense
the Jets big EDS are weighted mismatch
over the Raiders and they are an
underdog here that caught my attention
and the Jets are playing much better as
of late but that still caught me off
guard
number three weighted EDS are mismatched
Cowboys over Patriots in Burt your
reaction to that
I mean look no one's going to sit here
and defend the Patriots offense this
year they have it look dominant since
they won you know forty nothing over the
Dolphins in week two I mean they had a
couple of dominant wins over the
Redskins and over Luke Fox Jets yes
but they when when they played the
Ravens they got their clocks cleaned
when they played the Eagles that was a
very much could have gone either way one
fumble or one interception either way
that's a three-point game we'll get into
that came later yeah I just wanted your
initial reaction that's my initial
reaction is like I don't I don't really
believe that this Patriots offense in
its current form right right it could
round into shape will but in its current
form I am NOT up in arms that and to
walk around the streets of New York and
just start making bets about the
Patriots sure like if there's a time to
buy low in the Pats it is right freaking
now yeah that stock is dead oh it's so
good
alright and the fourth biggest weighted
EDS are matchup is the Titans over the
Jaguars so let me tell you a few things
that I got just from looking at both
lists number one there are two underdogs
in terms of the betting lines that have
a weighted EDS are advantage that caught
my attention I love underdogs thus far
in our season-long EDS are anytime that
an upset
popped up it's four and one so it's had
a good run thus far we are going to talk
about
New England later in terms of best games
but I first want to talk about one of
these underdogs Jets Raiders why don't
you set it up for us
the line where we stand with the money
and all that stuff and any interesting
nuggets yeah absolutely
the Raiders obviously six and four
heading into this matchup against a
three and seven Jets it's in New York
the line has gone from four and a half
Raiders favored to just three points so
people are betting the Jets that line is
going down and the total has actually
gone over in five of the last six games
for the Jets which I thought was
interesting so the over/under thing the
over/under currently listed at forty
seven point five which is a lot of
points but Oakland and the Jets they can
put up points they've been outperforming
Vegas his expectations of them when this
popped up I I said to Warren oh my lord
cleat Blakeman he's your guy yes cleat
Blakeman last week the under of the
Cleveland Pittsburgh game did in fact
hit that means that thus far this year
cleat Blakeman in the nine games he's
reffed the under his hit nine times nine
times incredible now the Browns they
were the favorite they won so that kind
of hurt his underdog record a little bit
cleat Blakeman in the in his last 14
games the underdog has covered the
spread 11 and 3 so I have jets with an
EDS are mismatched home against a West
Coast team at one o'clock which I know
isn't that big of a deal but I still
like mentioning it Raiders coming into
town and Clete Blakeman is roughing the
game I'm getting very excited this is
very good Warren omage right now we're
you're not using one data point no no no
we're using three or four data points to
sort of all mesh miss mash together to
point to the same pick so I told Warren
we got a cleat Blakeman sighting hmm
Warren said I love the Jets even before
you told me CLE Blakeman now he did say
this what is the current line the
current line is three no no the total
over/under is forty seven and a half
forty seven and a half let me see if
it's shifted it all but go ahead so
Warren told me he was leaning towards
the under early when it was at forty
eight if it's at forty seven and a half
yeah just check the update on that it's
now forty six and a half it so here it
goes
yeah so Warren said at around forty six
and a half there's
as much value he saw it more in the 45s
which it's still leaning towards the
under and maybe this is a game where you
hope it kind of gets bet up a little
better
but Warren did say Adam I do have a
concern it is the jet secondary they are
bad and he C worries that because
Oakland's offensive line is healthy now
and giving Derek Carr time heap they
might be able to pick apart the
secondary that is his concern obviously
Sam darn holds been kind of clicking
he's playing in Oakland secondary it's
not as bad as Miami and the Jets and
washing Miami the Giants in the
Washington dude Arnold's face chair but
it's not that great but because of my
love for this one data point I will be
betting the under this weekend in Jets
Raiders I'm gonna hope that the line
goes up at the same point I don't really
care if it gets to 46 I'm still gonna
bet it because I just want to be able to
yell cleat Blakeman it is it is a lot of
fun to root for the under and yell the
refs name that's great because I would
tell you man when it was brown Steelers
and there was one drive where I needed
the Steelers to come back and there were
two illegal hands to the faces a very
questionable personal foul call and a P
I on the same drive getting a yell CLE
Blakeman in my apartment by myself was a
rush that I haven't had in years so we
all love you know yelling Kobe when we
shoot yeah napkin into the trashcan I
think we should be the new thing we yell
when a plan where it could be Blakeman
but the problem is his first name is so
good I just love like you just win the
win the ball hits the foot for a punt
because you know it's just like yet
another drive that didn't result in
noise go clean I would do CLE really
there's nothing I like more than a
really big play under the yellow box
pops-up a spoon for me it's negating big
plays is what I'm hoping for from Clete
that's funny
there's something about watching a game
and a guy goes for a 50-yard run yeah
holding hands so Pete second down I'm
probably gonna do a Jets under my Jets
moneyline under parlay I love one of
those 50 bring me back you know 150 or
whatever that sounds great a 100 baby
back 333 but that was one of the things
again we're gonna get to Dallas New
England later
yeah second thing I learned from looking
at Warren's season-long Edie SR and as
he said blending it with the waited is
tennessee's on both Tennessee last time
I checked was sitting as a three point
favorite over the Jaguars where's it at
now the Jaguars right now yeah Tennessee
Jacksonville right it's a tiniest tent
Titans minus three okay the over-under
is at 41 and a half Jaguars did win 20
to 7 last time obviously both teams had
different that was see that was the
Gardner Minshew breakout mercenary
football game where I bet yeah I made a
lot of money on unday Lee fantasy on
that game that was great so that was
Minshew versus Mariota and now we've
honestly got two very different guys
okay so that's what Warren told me he
said okay look new quarterbacks it's
night and day but the problem is when
you're looking at metrics like EDS are
Jacksonville has a new quarterback and
since he's only played for one week
there's not enough numbers in the system
and as we talked about with Doug Marrone
if Doug Marrone does in fact run the
ball with Leonard fournette Jacksonville
could be a lot scarier here but
Tennessee has not faced a run offense as
bad as Jacksonville in the last six
weeks the Jacksonville has to run the
ball
but when Jacksonville has played good
run defenses three points against
Houston six points against New England
twelve points against Houston 26 against
Denver and remember Denver just couldn't
get any offense going and kept putting
that out that Jacksonville offense on
the field but he did say this I'll get
to this last point he really doesn't
like Tennessee at all he doesn't like
their offensive coordinator he doesn't
trust their head coaches he really
prefers Jacksonville's offensive
coordinator defillippo
comes from a pass-first background so it
plays a lot better to the EDS our
matchups he said I know they're popping
up on both metrics I don't like this
game
and I understand it look if you're still
out there and you're still thinking
about putting money on this game in
either direction you can just call the
jaguars team line that the phone numbers
on their website and Doug Marrone will
get on the phone and tell you how much
they're planning on running the ball
we're gonna run it all the time he'll
let you know which downs are
it's very helpful it's a nice hotline I
just you know what I I think
this off season or maybe throughout the
rest of this year I'd like to construct
a left go betting Bible and it's not one
that I think other people should
subscribe to it's just ones that I would
like to nice to have rules that you
follow over the course of a year even if
it's wrong a few times like it's nice to
have a system and I like when they're
abstract rules like like commandment one
might be when in doubt don't bet on
Jameis Winston okay yeah like if you're
not sure don't bet on Jameis Winston
I've lost so much money on Jameis
Winston this year bet number two don't
bet on matchups in the AFC South I
believe that there is no division that I
have understood less in the last five
years than the Titans the Texans the
Jaguars and the Colts none of it makes
sense to me
they all have weird little rivalries all
of their quarterbacks are unreliable or
often sacked and I just I always find
myself betting on Titans Colts and so
when I see Titans Jags I just I don't
want to be a part of it that's gonna be
one of my commandments my commandment
and this is true for poker this is true
for sports gambling just the commandment
that I have in the back of my head is
don't get cute just try to win money
don't get cute it's so easy to get cute
it is hey you know who's going on the
road and maybe it just stop just try to
win money that's my brain all right the
last really big nugget that I took from
EDS are because we're gonna talk about
49ers Packers later because I think that
jumped out to me too yeah I don't want
to spend time on Saints Panthers I don't
like talking about big lines I'd rather
talk about the little lines but the
biggest one was I said hey man that's
really interesting in the traditional
matchup that the bills are a big matchup
over the Broncos and Warren came out and
said I love the over 36 and a half is
the over-under right now that's that's
not a lot of points at all set it up for
me yeah and I'm gonna tell you why our
Warren sharp like see over in a game in
which Brandon Allen is facing the bills
defense and Shawn McDermott and Josh
Allen is facing Vic Fangio and the
Bronco
it doesn't sound like it makes sense but
I got it for you what does the game
setup like right now we've got Broncos
at Bill's a line open at minus-5 the
over-under is at 36 and a half obviously
the Broncos three and seven going
against the seven and three bills
Brandon Allen even though he's a rookie
and kind of not with highly-touted has
got really frightening hands 24 points
and 23 points in the last two weeks you
know right there you're two-thirds of
the way to the / right you know if you
can do something close to that
Broncos five and one against the spread
in their last six games they have been
outperforming they've had the perfect
cacophony of playing certain teams that
underperformed that had to go to mile
high a new quarterback coming in and
everyone doubting him so those were like
- and and to be honest Brandon Allen has
has had some great plays that first
three quarters against Minnesota some of
the deep balls he was dropping into
Courtland Sutton were beautiful I know
that Noah fan play was a little freakish
but he was able to drive the ball up and
down on Cleveland that's a really good
defense but this is gonna be a little
bit of an infomercial for sharp football
analysis calm but when I warrant is not
this guy that goes here's my pick he
goes I'm gonna give you an eight
paragraph rundown on why I chose this
and when you get done hearing it you go
that is such a lock a lead-pipe lock tip
that I have to take it so I see I see I
see I see my client launch off believes
that the bills and the Broncos will go
over on Sunday I'm talking like this
because my plan is ironclad my evidence
is perfection and your excuses will pop
off of me like Teflon number one do you
know young man wear offensive
coordinator brian de bal coached last
week against miami it was different
do you know would you like to guess the
voice is getting in my head I'm like
missing the question itself you asked
please just answer yourself oh okay
should I keep talking like this ergo
it's funny to me I just it's really hard
to focus on the information when there's
so many trappings happening outside last
week for the first time all year yeah
off
of coordinator for the bills brian de ba
coached upstairs in the booth oh I see
not from the sideline and all of a
sudden he was able and he talked about
it because coaches talked said I was
able to talk into Josh Allen's headset a
little bit longer and I saw more of the
formations Wow
number two the bills switched to an
up-tempo offense last week and Brian day
ball came out afterwards and said that
is going to continue think about this
weeks one through ten it took them about
28 seconds between snaps last week 24.8
and you go what's three point two if
they did twenty four point eight the
whole year that's what the Rams are the
fastest team in the NFL that's how
quickly it jumped up so in a week brian
de bois-guilbert FC offensive player of
the week yeah he look smooth sorry for
spitting bonus note that isn't even part
of my top five this is all available in
short full football analysis this is how
good warren is Buffalo is number three
in NFL red zone conversion rate so when
they get down there they score and
they're gonna be going more up temp and
that's been true all year that's not
like a random stats that's popped up I
remember a week five they said something
like that that he was at 75% they just
keep converting in the red zones they
pound the rock and they get it done yeah
number three Denver has the number 10
ranked rushing attack and it is the
toughest matchup the Bills have faced
since the Eagles who was number nine
what did the Eagles do in that game I
remember vividly I was in London they
ran for 218 yards on the bills five
point three yards per carry and mile
Sanders ran wild here comes Philip
Lindsay
not only that we talked about the
Patriots easy schedule we talked about
the Niners easy schedule do not forget
that Buffalo schedule was very easy - or
so easy in fact the number one schedule
of opposing offenses
the number one easiest pass and the
number one easiest run maybe this bills
defense is a little overrated because
even though they faced the easiest run
in past defenses they are 27th against
the run Phillip Lindsay and the Denver
Broncos just last week made Phillip
Lindsay their lead back their number one
they started getting rid of Royce
Freeman Carey's yes so this is a little
daily fantasy nugget I as a fantasy
owner of Royce Freeman have noticed his
his like this here well I know no one
cares about my fantasy team but I'm
sorry to you sir what a bummer I know
what alligators get arm grass and all
them teeth and no toothbrush what's
happening but to that if you're saying
let's say I play daily fantasy yeah and
Phillip Lindsey's goat up a really tough
Buffalo team or you're like me and you
have Buffalo's defense maybe you don't
feel so confident in it number four as
you mentioned earlier a lot of people
are worried about Brandon Allen when it
comes to betting this over why are you
worried
23 points against Cleveland a very good
defense 24 points in Minnesota against
Mike Zimmer are you saying that I came
up with the same stat independently that
Warren Sharpe did this might be like the
highlight of my prognostication life
you nailed it oh my god what a day what
a day hello camera
lastly to show you
Warren sharps incredible power and the
reason why I needed him on this show and
the reason why I do not hesitate to say
if you want some really good information
I value sharp football analysis calm
these two teams Buffalo and Denver are
31 and 32 in punt efficiency mmm - worst
punt units in the NFL short fields
getting the ball down there great field
position who else in their analysis to
discuss an over has the foresight to go
and look at pond efficiency ice
that Warren Sharpe does I rest my case
the over loving it the jury just came
back and they're in there in sharp
agreement they like the agreement yeah
what is the over/under so right now I'm
seeing the over-under at 37 and a half
hmmm so it's popped up since I wrote
these notes last night then what does
you have it up I had it at 36 and a half
oh man I don't know got it 37 and a half
at most places here yeah so I still
think that looks good anytime Warren
gives me stuff like that it could go to
40 and I'd be like yeah I'll take it now
I know there's obviously like a probably
four window if he really likes it
usually there's a little bit of variance
there but yeah man when he started
giving me all those nuggets I was like
alright bills Broncos were riding that
wagon yep when you hear all that like
what is it like to think does it get you
excited that you feel like you're on the
in it does yeah I mean hearing this
information throughout the year has been
very instructive I you know for people
that don't know I'm in the booth sort of
listening yeah and all this stuff and
I'm in your ear a few times kind of
throw throwing a little little nugget
here and there but just listening to
Warren Sharpe it's as I said over the
summer we were talking about it my
favorite thing in the world is watching
someone who's really good at what they
do do what they do I don't care if
you're a three-point shooting specialist
I don't care if you're the world's best
gardener I don't care if you're the
world's best stonemason watching someone
that's really good at what they do do
their thing is just something we should
all appreciate and Warren Sharpe is
really good at putting these numbers
together and then when I look at the
bills and I think about that defense
just to add a little bit more context
Miami was going up and down the field
they hung 20 points on Buffalo and if
you remember I think it was either right
before the half or right after the half
there was a huge catch and run by Allen
Hurns that was coming for 50 yards and
he just got a hit and fumbled it so
there could be more points on the board
the Cleveland Brown game
don't forget Cleveland had like seven or
eight plays within the two yard line and
left with three points so Cleveland
again was driving up and down the field
that was also the first game where they
changed the lines in the end zone to
vertical instead of horizontal utilizing
more of positive vision to invite into
the end zone this is a mark Sessler take
from around the NFL he petitioned it
they did it and Cleveland's offense has
been
look ever since I love story lines like
that that is like what's that woman on
Amazon Netflix that brings joy and
organism Marie Kondo it's like it's as
if Marie Kondo went to Cleveland and
said vertical stripes that horizontal
she said get rid of all of the things in
your life that are not sparking joy on
this team yes only focus on the
horizontal stripes and the game before
that was Washington which was Dwayne
Haskins first game like kind of starting
so I just I love that one
all right a little left go bye week
update there are people in this office
that loved including your podcast
partner Jake Strasser focusing on teams
coming after a bye yes I went back and
looked it up thus far this season teams
off of a bi straight up in their next
game are eight and 16 against the spread
eight and 15 and I did want to notice
that there were two matchups this year
in which there were two teams facing
each other after a bye wash so it's kind
of a wash there were a few of those in
there where it was like right up coming
off the Bayou were at 40 Niners or at
Saints I noticed there were a few games
in there that were tough wins straight
up but yeah yeah against the spread
numbers are actually pretty startling
and then I think last week teams off of
a bi were one in five right straight up
and 2 and 4 against the spread the way
that I always think about it and this is
not analytical at all this is very much
beer football I feel like if a team is
clicking before a bye that's when I want
to bet against them and if a team was
struggling before a bye I kind of want
to bet with them and I know I'm taking
one data point but I'm thinking about
Atlanta goes into the bye and it's
exactly what they needed and then I
think about the Saints going to a bi or
these other teams that went to a bi and
it kind of felt it's just ruining the
momentum so it's like if you're if
you're I literally in a great analytical
show just brought up one data point and
the word momentum
I felt criminal yeah someone will be
very quickly debunking everything you
just said with numbers but who cares
yeah so what you're saying just sort of
anecdotally the feeling is that if
things are going well you don't want to
take that extra fat off and that's
always the the argument people get about
getting the 1 seed of the 2 seed right
if the
if you're the to seat and you lose that
first home game in the playoffs everyone
says see they took two weeks off and
they couldn't get it together they just
didn't remember the speed of the game
but if they win they go see they needed
those two weeks in January to get
everybody you know everyone was banged
up there remember when the Lakers were
decisive of course Lakers played the
Sixers Game one of the NBA Finals and
the Lakers swept everybody and the
Sixers went to like three straight
seven-game series and the Lakers had
like two weeks off they lost game 1 and
Allen Iverson 2001 Iverson went off for
57 points but the narrative was it was
too much time off for the Lakers there
yeah you can go either way and then but
what usually happens is the other team
comes back and wins four straight
because they're very well rested that
game one is the Iverson walking over
tyloo that's that moment yeah I I
remember every part of that night that I
remember Raja bells big shot I remember
Eric snow got stuck in the lane and just
shot it and made it dikembe mutombo got
like a block on Shaq I was great so the
team's coming off of buys this week two
of them are interesting to me the two of
that are not so interesting Giants
coming off of a by taking on Chicago
Chicago and absolute free fall I believe
they're what six point favorites right
now yeah the Giants it opened at seven
and a half it's been bet down to six
gotcha
another one Tennessee coming off of a
bye we talked about them already ETS are
mismatches in both but the two that are
coming off a bye that are interesting to
me Seahawks coming off of that monster
win against San Francisco now going to
Philadelphia one o'clock game they're
not coming off of bye and the Packers
coming off of a bye to take on the
Niners Sunday Night Football let's talk
about the one o'clock game Seattle at
Philadelphia Seahawks coming off of a
bye where where did the line start where
is it now
it was Seahawks plus three it's now down
to plus two but I will say the most
interesting thing I noted about this
game is that it is the third most public
team of the week 82 percent of the bets
are on the Seahawks right now so much so
that right now I'm seeing that I'm
seeing a few one and a half's and even
more ones in Vegas
so it's being bet what percentage 82
percent of the bet
and you don't know how much money that
is correct one bet could come in and be
you know as much as a sharp a sharp side
but it means that it's a very public
team right now that a lot of people with
twenty to a hundred dollar range are
going to the window and saying I'd like
to see hawks plus one and a half plus
two plus three that's why it got bet
down obviously and now it's going to
have three two one
a Warren's first sentence about this
game I hate everything about this game
the sharp side will be on Philadelphia
so if you're someone that loves to bet
against the public and I know there's a
lot of people that make a lot of money
like that yeah your bet in Philly and I
would say let this line continue to go
there there might be a chance where you
get you get points with Philadelphia in
this game it's gonna get bets so much to
that side Philadelphia is in free fall
right now I just saw a bleacher report
article in which it says when's doesn't
trust his wide receivers his wide
receivers don't trust him
the coach is being questioned publicly
the wide receivers are being completely
derided this team is in free fall
Seattle Russel Wilson
even in a bye week is your leader in MVP
voting right now
the Niners have a little bit of
questions I'm seeing people saying the
Seahawks could take that division so
it's getting that big Warren know said
Adam keep this in mind again about
Seattle they barely beat Cleveland they
lost to Baltimore they barely beat Tampa
Bay in overtime they were down handedly
against San Francisco until they got all
those defensive scores like Jadeveon
Clowney the public perception right now
is what you saw on Monday Night Football
and the fact they have Russell Wilson
don't forget what the Eagles defense has
now done the last few weeks shutting
down New England and looking a lot
better in wins over Buffalo and Chicago
now he said his big concern is with the
Eagles secondary even though they've got
a lot of guys back it could just turn
into Russ P and Russ yep and when you're
betting against Russel Wilson
it's the scariest thing ever but if
you're going to bet this game you got to
go on the sharp side here to
Philadelphia you have to this it's at
home too this is the perfect example of
what I was
at the start of this podcast which is
that I'm here to just present the
ingestion it's out there this feels like
when Cleveland Browns were favored over
the bills at home and the the Browns
were two and six and the bills were
sixty how is this possible what the hell
is happening why is the two and sixteen
favored over the six and two you could
say the same thing right now you just
look at the numbers you say okay single
very similar field goals are five and
five Seahawks are eight and two explain
to me why the Seahawks aren't you know a
three three and a half four point
favorite in this well you know in that
case a lot of the public money was on
the bills and it didn't come through the
Browns won yes
they won out well why three and it was
like the perfect line but this one that
one the line stayed at three all week
long but people were confused by it all
it was that was the chatter I thought
Lee but I'm just saying it's interesting
though that this one is dropping you
know what I mean yeah there's a lot of
money there's a there must be a lot of
money and the percentage you take your
cent
eighty-two percent of the tickets are on
the Seahawks as according to the numbers
that I found in a few different sites if
I was also gonna look back into our
podcast from week six or seven I was
saying that the Eagles were gonna beat
the Seahawks at home mm-hmm and so I
don't want to forget that I knew they
were going to lose to the Patriots and
then here comes the second game the
Eagles play better when they're
underdogs they play better when they're
angry they pay better coming off of a
loss don't forget when they got
shellacked by the Cowboys they went to
Buffalo and won by 18 this is not that
great of a Seahawks defense but at the
same point I know that I'm not gonna bet
on this game but there's part of me with
I would rather root it would matter that
would rather well my money to be with
Russel Wilson in a pinch than Carson
Wentz in this offense in the pinch yeah
but all the side like my brain saying
bet Eagles in this game one more thing
to bring up just because it's pretty
interesting with Russell Wilson five and
OH straight up on the road this year two
and three at home he's obviously going
into Philadelphia just throwing it up
you know a lot of people say hey West
Coast going to the East Coast team it's
a one o'clock game yeah
but Russell Wilson has been undefeated
on the road which is very impressive
even if it's you know minor wins winning
by one winning but ever it's still
impressive I believe this was supposed
to have been a Sunday Night Football
game and it got flexed out and it kind
of screwed my
from getting to go to the game well it's
because it's it's Packers 49ers right
yeah exactly that's tough to beat at
this point it's interesting too but like
Seahawks Eagles you're like that house
okay two months ago I would have been
like hell yeah that sounds great yeah
all right big 4 o'clock game Dallas at
New England
remember again in terms of weighted EDS
are the third biggest mismatch of the
week was Cowboys over Patriots
I said Warren how is this possible
before I get to that
why don't you said this came up for us
we've got Cowboys at Patriots Patriots
just played the NFC East rivals of the
eagle you know he goes last week just
barely beat them and in a pretty
slugfest e-type game Patriots line
opened at 7 it's now been bet down to
six and a half the over/under is hovered
around 46 the money line around - 290
for the Patriots which feels pretty
heavy juice that means that I feel like
a lot of people are betting that the
Patriots will win this game will win it
outright even if they are there's not so
much confidence that they'll cover so
over the last four weeks
Dallas's offense and New England's
offense in terms of EDS are Dallas seven
New England 24 checks out mm-hmm
the narrative DAX been great Tom Brady
in that office hasn't been clicking also
two times offense I don't want to keep
[ __ ] on Tom here oh there's how many
weapons right now
no I just want to get that out there III
think you of you you've caveated enough
times this season that it's like if we
if we say anything negative about Tom
Brady it's just simply in the context of
what just happened no one's pouring dirt
on the team you know he'll be fine we'll
figure it out [ __ ] everybody on Twitter
a New England on defense New England's
EDS are is 18 Dallas as 19 so the reason
we have such a big math mismatch in the
eds ours is mainly Dallas's offense both
defenses in the last month have been
below average which is interesting
especially because New England we were
talking about a month ago but Warren
kind of predicted it with the schedule
change I do think if you're just looking
at the last four games to the Ravens
game is going to skew their numbers
although their rush defense looked
terrible and then before that
Cleveland's ability to run on them added
to that as well Warren's biggest concern
is the coach coaching mismatch which
obviously you could say that every
Patriots came even more so any Patriots
Cowboys
because the balichek garrett mismatch is
a wow it's a beautiful one apart from
the Ravens game if you take that one out
teams against New England in the second
quarter are averaging 2.2 points and in
the fourth quarter one point frickin one
those are the quarters where Belichick
adjusts and then when he figures you out
you do nothing in seven of the last nine
games they have held their opponents
scoreless in the fourth quarter
think about that in seven last nine
games if you play the Patriots you have
not scored in the fourth one of those
two was Baltimore like we know that was
like a very big outlier game your
defense is insane and crunch time it's
always you give it to me thank you
yeah you did it I did now when it comes
to Dallas their defense has done
slightly better in the second half but
nothing notable what is interesting
about this matchup is the Cowboys are
averaging about nine points per game in
the fourth quarter a pretty solid number
and they're going up against the New
England defense it will be very
interesting to watch if Dallas is
battling back in the fourth quarter how
they do the big question I had about the
the Dallas defense I said Warren what
scares you the most about Dallas defense
he's at their pass rush yeah not being
able to get to Brady their past rush
ranks 25th and Isaiah Wynn has a chance
to come back and in terms of getting
teams off the field on third down
Dallas is 30th so if you're not gonna
get to Brady and your D line really is
not generating pressure and DeMarcus
Lawrence was banged up at the end of
last game and you are already the third
worst team in the NFL and getting teams
off the field on third down and there's
no one that breaks the back of their
opponent more by extending drives on
third down than the Patriots even if
it's Rex Burkhead on a dump off or a
random out throw to Matlock Oz it's the
frickin Patriots yeah so there's an adsr
advantage for Dallas
as a Patriots fan I'm just curious where
you stand in Foxborough Dallas coming up
there and getting a really big test I
just want to know where you stand so
again this is caveat yes the gambling
podcast this is just me as a fan this
Patriots team needs a stomp down win
they need to get back on that track if
they're if they have aspirations of
getting their seventh Superbowl which I
know is insane
but if they have aspirations of that
they need to start stomping some teams
and I think a home win after a couple of
shaky weeks you know that Ravens loss is
still just very much reverberating in
Pats nation a lot of people are just
very worried about that game we need the
1 seed no one wants to go back into
Baltimore no one wants to go to
Arrowhead if it ends up working out like
that no one wants to go to any of these
other places and play a playoff game so
we we we don't want to rest and say like
hey you know we'll get to the playoffs
with 1112 wins we need to get to the
1314 wins because we need to play these
games in Foxborough and this is a great
week to say hey you know who's amazing
in Foxborough Tom Brady it doesn't
matter if people are banged up doesn't
matter if we have our weapons this is
the week where we make our stand and say
hey we've got the weapons we're gonna do
this this is a Dallas defense that gave
up 24 to the Jets they just faced Jeff
Driskel
and allowed 27 points they did and this
is definitely a Dallas teen I think's
flying high it's been a great week for
dak Prescott MVP discussions I partook
in that a lot the line is on is I would
wait on this game and let it get bet
down even more for people trying to
capture that number for the Cowboys I
agree with everything you said great
it's a 4 o'clock game in Foxborough
I feel like anytime that I ever have
seen the Patriots slip its those one
o'clock games in Foxborough they just
kind of start a little bit slow then
they get the Machine rolling but with
Dallas at 4 o'clock dak has been a very
good primetime performer if you look at
the statistics and primetime games he's
been great but for me this is absolutely
the hey Dallas
slow your roll a little bit because the
Patriots they need that statement win I
I agree with you completely from the
Dallas side - this is gonna be a
cold-ass game you know obviously the the
Cowboys are a dome team if Ezekiel
Elliot wants to put all the doubters to
bed
this is the game to do it and say hey
this is good oh it has to be the Z game
yeah this is gonna be the toughest
defense that Amari Cooper and Michael
Gallup have faced all year right very
good secondary a lot of pics dak
Prescott is gonna be rolling out this is
a football take on a gambling show the
thing that I'm excited the most about
this game is to see who Belichick tries
to get to beat him hmm if Belichick
because all year it sort of been like
will let dak beat us last year last week
dak just faced Patricia so Belichick has
a very similar schemes attack on how to
face the Cowboys and dak did it
perfectly so in a weird way I think
Belichick has an even better blueprint
for the two teams that play the most
man-to-man coverage in the NFL or the
Detroit Lions and the New England
Patriots the difference is the Detroit
Lions are completely banged up and have
a bottom five pass defense the Patriots
are not banged up and they have a top
five pass defense Gilmore can go on
Cooper or does he put Gilmore on gallop
because what Belichick is always done is
put his number one corner on the number
two wide receiver and then use the
middle of the field then put everything
exactly but Cooper's a little bit banged
up this is a fascinating game that we
are gonna leave and go what blueprint
did Belichick give us and is he more
afraid of Zeke or dak because if he
shows no respect to Zeke at all
Monday mornings gonna be amazing every
show is gonna be just yelling quick fun
little trivia question for you okay
the Cowboys are one of how many teams
that Brady is undefeated against in his
career Wow do you have his record
against the Cowboys just for reference
they are for an O all-time against
that's and you know what for two decades
to Decca right you play them every four
or five years he probably had like some
beatable Dallas Cowboys teams early and
some tough ones late so he is undefeated
which is perfect because this week
LeBron James became the first player to
get record a triple-double against every
team in the NFL I love guys that have
been around this long my favorite my
favorite stat in that vein is that Fred
McGriff at some point held the record he
had hit a home run in
42 different ballparks it's like just
because he'd been in at both Al and NL I
just he just played for long you know
who he has to thank you outlasted
stadiums who Tommy a man ski yeah I'm
Fred McGriff and I liked I'm a skis
workout video I would say Tom Brady is
undefeated because there's gonna be
someone a nose and some - a nose - all
of these are four or more wins he's
putting every team in that yeah I'm
gonna say he's undefeated against eight
teams with five teams okay
all NFC teams it's the boys Falcons
bears Vikings Buccaneers cuz I mean
every AFC team he's never played you
know does doesn't whatever yeah and even
though he's like 33 and three against
the bear the bills
yeah the lost you know yeah right Wow
but I thought that was a fun crazy step
but he's never lost to the Cowboys and I
have no idea if he even knows that but
that'd be fun I'm doing a lot of NBA
stuff because obviously it's on my mind
a little bit but you know it's when you
when you hear statistics about the the
Warriors run mm-hmm and you go man we're
gonna look back at that 50 years ago
what the hell yeah and we said this
about NFL for a long time about passing
statistics right now compared to like
like 50 years ago it doesn't even make
sense yeah but this Patriots run we are
gonna look back at this reign and I know
a lot of people say that's a statistic
that will never be beaten I just don't
see a coach quarterback combo having a
two decade reign of trips to the AFC
Championship game and Super Bowls and
this level of regular-season dominance I
just don't because we've never seen
anything close to it before right yeah I
just don't think we'll ever see anything
close to it again it's so much it is a
fun thing to be a part of I can't
imagine what it's like to be rooting for
that team yeah so New England I just
looked this up in the in the line of
like we're just gonna look back and
that's freaking crazy the Patriots have
covered the spread 58 percent of the
time since 2003 so if you would just bet
the spread I'll be one of the greatest
gamblers in Vegas right you would have
been super profitable every year for 94
16 straight I don't I just do that every
game I mean at this point you're kind of
getting on the lines have adjusted to
Thomas skills but there is a but I feel
like they're probably still covering
their 7 and 3 against the spread this
year that's pretty good 70
% yeah I mean if if I was hitting 70%
the time I'd start a website yeah left
go football analysis comp we're coming
for you sure sharp football analysis
models are covering 71% of the time
random that's insane
all right Packers Niners this was an
adsr mismatch it was a traditional one
this is not weighted Niners over Packers
I say that because it's a little bit
scary when you look at the Niners
opponents why don't you set this came up
before I kind of get into it yep this is
Packers at 49ers classic Niners by three
that's just Vegas saying these teams are
about equal we'd over-under won an
over/under 1/2 of a clip of Brett Favre
versus Steve Young and this game it's
Sunday Night Football the ever yeah that
feels over ish to me yeah I think so -
all right get back to the game sorry
about that
so yeah the over over/under is at 46 the
early money appears to be leaning toward
the Packers is what I've seen so you
know the the underdog money is coming in
Road Dogg George kid all still
day-to-day Emanuel Sanders still not a
hundred percent and most importantly
when dealing with the Packers is that
everyone should go online and listen to
the Greg Jennings podcast that you did
yesterday yes go listen to the Greg
Jennings podcast where Greg Jennings was
wildly honest unbelievable what a guest
and truly he has been known for a little
bit of being a quote Aaron Rodgers hater
and he addressed it and I think it's a
really good listen I just sat there and
kept going left go shut the [ __ ] up in
my own head I just kept going yep don't
talk don't talk don't talk okay I'm
gonna give you guys a little bit of a
nugget and I'm just telling you the
truth here I know I'm I know I'm like
pimping out Warren's website but it's
only because you believe in the product
I believe in the product and he is a
part of this show and I want to support
him so chef Apple announces calm or it
really likes the over ah what is the
total right now 46 okay if you think
about the Niners defense and the Packers
defense this could be very interesting
in terms of the offenses that the Niners
have faced they have faced seven teams
this season in the first games before
this last three stretch in which the
offense they faced has been either 18th
or below and they only allowed 20 points
once and that was part of the reason we
had this narrative that the Niners were
an all-time great defense well in the
last three weeks with Arizona and with
Seattle they have faced the number 9
offense twice number 4 offense and they
allowed 25 27 26 Green Bay's offense is
ranked 5th so they went through a
stretch of facing 24 29
18:21 2031 25 and we were going while
the Niners T is great last three weeks
trending bad the last five weeks
the Niners pass-rush has faced in terms
of offensive line 29 27 25 20 25 now
they're facing 10 so the Niners have
relied on their pass rush toughest
offensive line they faced they have been
destroying tough offenses they are now
facing the 5th best offense but if you
also look at it in terms of how they've
been doing in run defense in the last
three weeks they are the worst
trending run defense in the NFL Wow and
here comes Aaron Jones now the Packers
are coming off of a bye so it's gonna be
interesting to see how it kind of goes a
lot of rust a lot of rust versus rest
but do not sleep on the Niners run
offense - this is why Warren Sharpeville
ball analysis calm is loving the Niners
offense as well even without Kittel
if obviously you want kiddle and
Emmanuel Sanders banged up the Green Bay
Packers have the fifth worst run defense
in the NFL and we've known that we've
talked about that a lot this year
the Niners have actually faced some
tough run defenses and only two times
have they faced a team that's bottom 10
run defense Carolina and Cincinnati they
hung up 51 on Carolina 41 on Cincinnati
and Tevin Coleman and rot where he most
her in both games were averaging over
five yards to carry so now they're
facing Green Bay on Sunday Night
Football with a banged up defense ready
to be run on the bottom line is this and
I'm taking all of this from short
football analysis because Warren is a
[ __ ] monster and he's amazing
to offenses that are top ten in the red
zone both run defenses are trending as
the 31 and 32nd run defenses now this
sounds like this is also good for daily
fantasy if you want to get on the Jamal
Williams the Aaron Jones the rahim most
hurts the Tevin Coleman two paths past
offenses that are diverse and aggressive
he it sounds like an amazing Sunday
night football game oh sure it sounds
like one I'm very excited to watch you
hear that he didn't do anything with
sides just total does that excite you oh
yeah for sure my question that I would I
would love to know if you got it from
Warren or I may have so let's hear it
the last three weeks as you mentioned
they've given up 25 27 and 26 points to
Kyler Murray and Russell Wilson two very
mobile quarter means obviously Aaron
Rodgers he's not super fleet of foot but
he's very good at picking up that first
down on third and four if things open up
for him predict the future yeah could
this be Aaron Rodgers most mobile game
this season I was wondering that like I
didn't know if Warren had numbers on
that or if that's maybe part of Matloff
Loras game plan that it's like hey Aaron
you know this this team might be a
little vulnerable to a little bit of
scampering here and there are they gonna
kind of build that into their plan a bit
interesting I do like that and I do
think that if we watch this game and we
start seeing maybe a little bit more of
a stag enough and so we can go maybe
it's the mobile quarterback factor right
so we'll think about that there but I
think this is an exciting game for me it
is in California Aaron Rodgers going
back home to California the bye week
scares me a lot I learned a lot about
the Niners last week the fact that they
started off down 16 and battled back
yeah and Jimmy Garoppolo I thought with
debo Samuels as number one wide receiver
was great for me I am waiting on George
Kittel yeah I had a shot to him
from up in the booth I felt like they
went to him like the or the know players
you're aware that cameras are on who was
George Kettle bad Panda Express double
orange chicken George kennel but I am if
I have Gronk on my podcast on Monday and
he says that George Kittles the best
tight end of the league playing in an
offense that utilizes tight ends the
best in the league yeah and he's had two
weeks now to rest if George Kido plays
I'm a lot more bullish on the Niners
sure if he doesn't I'm probably looking
more at player props for the Packers
because I bet you Aaron Jones's numbers
are a little bit lower because people
think that the Niners run defense is
gonna be good if George Keitel is out is
Ross dwelle a nice DFS pick up I mean he
had two touchdowns last week in the Kyle
Shanahan offense he can plug in anybody
yeah and they will do well it's give me
a 6 jeff wilson jr. rahim most hurt matt
Breda Tevin Coleman dwelle
[ __ ] he'll give you a failed wide
receiver coming back to look good
playing game that dude with the crazy
hair that caught the touchdown
Donte Pettis it doesn't matter anybody
that goes into Kyle Shanahan's offense
he's getting you paid he'll get Pierre
garçon paid he get me paid if you have a
little bit of quick tips ability and can
play in the slot
yes all right Kyle I'll give you my
number at this would you be ingmar
senior oh no well no because there's no
I don't have a son whose name is so what
ok I'll go up throw this out though the
SR period on the day you used your name
David as your daughter's middle name
could you claim senior first of all that
you have to be a different level of
psycho to do that but one of my fiance's
middle names is Jimmy really multiple
middle name it's also it's not a Jewish
thing that's really bro in back tracking
mode but Jewish people don't actually my
grandfather passed away too you know so
yeah it's I guess it's customary to kind
of add the father yet I guess there's a
Jewish thing yeah we don't do anything
no tattoos no names
yeah don't know anything about your past
Jews are like let's keep it clean ok
last game of note Ravens Rams Ravens at
the Rams Rams Plus 3 in the Super
content
what did you have as of last night and
I'll check now - right now I have it as
still as three for Baltimore in LA oh I
had Ravens two and a half but no
possible it's gotten better pin the
recent yeah yeah three three is it
opened that Baltimore - one really
interesting mm-hmm
what else do you do you have any other
notes or is it because it's Monday it's
a little bit early no I have a couple of
notes them the most fun one is I saw a
stat from at PFF fantasy they had most
avoided tackles by a QB this year number
four Cuyler Mary Murray he's avoid Mary
Tyler Murray has avoid six tackles
present number three Jacoby Brissette
has avoided seven tackles l'ombre - Josh
Allen has avoided 13 tackles I want to
guess number one Lamar Jackson has
avoided 2629 tackle I was there I was
gonna say wow just so fun just well more
than 29 second 30 n-- 7-6 yeah so it's
like you put a finger on Lamar Jackson
whoop see you later and what's
incredible is I feel like we've seen a
few where he may have evaded six tackles
in one play right well 29 that puts you
after 10 games it's about three a game
he avoids three sacks per game just on
sheer force of skill and evasive Ness
Warren's big note here was this is
probably going to be the most lopsided
bet game on Monday Night Football this
year he said the books will massively be
needing the Rams so if you want to bet
Ravens Rams if you want to be that
Seahawks
Eagles if you want to bet with Vegas you
bet eagles Rams this was also write this
exactly this is my my other points the
Ravens were the second most public team
I said the Seahawks were the third most
public team with 82 percent of the money
the Ravens are the second most public
team with 83 percent of the money which
is obviously why the number has come
down from three and a half more than 82
percent yeah I'm saying they're the
number two most public team oh isn't a
three more than 81 yes I'm saying the
Ravens have 83 percent of the money the
Seahawks have 82 percent of the money
Seahawks are the third most public who's
one number one is the Lions over the
Redskins at eighty five percent of the
money but it's like you can't you can't
really count the Redskins like obviously
anyone that plays the Redskins at this
point is going to become the most public
team almost this week yeah it's good to
bet against Haskins but oh yeah but in
terms of just what I found interesting
is that the Ray
and the Seahawks playing the Rams and
the Eagles respectively two very
competitive games good teams teams with
playoff aspirations teams that are
definitely nice in tank job no way right
very very public teams the Ravens with
83% of the pen that number is probably
gonna go up because everyone's gonna
lose their bet Sunday and then bet on
the Ravens and like no one wants to be
betting against Lamar Jackson under the
national spotlight right especially with
like the Rams not looking that great
they're gonna go they beat the Bears but
also the Rams their offensive line
they've made some changes it actually
looked a little bit better they ran
Gurley a little bit more but it's also
like this is what warrants the Rams D is
very good they've played a very easy
schedule of offenses even though
Baltimore's run defense I was listening
to Mena Kimes and Aaron shots of
football outsiders talked about theirs
secretly the Ravens run defense hasn't
been that good and it's sort of like
they've done a run funnel where they let
you run on them because they're more
afraid of the past and their secondaries
got a lot better he doesn't think that
the Rams are gonna be able to establish
a run early his biggest fear if you are
betting with Vegas is that the Rams get
down early and all of your money is on
Jared Goff right and that's a very scary
proposition and he said that it's gonna
eventually be you're betting on Lamar or
Jared Goff and he said but you need to
ask yourself do you want to bet with
Vegas and then I texted Warren I never
know how to answer that question and
then Warren didn't respond to me and
then I went to sleep so so that's the
recommendation [ __ ] bro he was like he
was like it just depends if you want to
bet with Vegas and I was like I never
know how to answer that is that his mic
drop is that his like look man if you
want to be one of those guys that vets
you know I think he went and vomited
let's put on mustaches and call crack
can we call crack yeah I mean we're a
little bit behind what we said we would
call him at because we've been having a
good time talking NFL but yeah he's in
New York right now actually he's not in
Vegas he's going to a charity dinner
tonight I don't know is he here right
now he's in New York I was like if
you're punking me right now no he we're
gonna we're gonna give him
call hopefully he's around but he's not
in Vegas this week oh I just got an
alert on my Bleacher Report app the BR
app you're gonna get the app miles
Garrett alleges Steelers quarterback
Mason Rudolph called him a racial slur
hello hey crack
that's good perfect timing how you doing
bro good buddy let's go um you guys I
hear you're in New York welcome back to
the East Coast
thanks man I'm going through a charity
dinner tonight for my buddy Teddy Atlas
yeah so it should be good guy hey so
Warren's really sick right now so I got
ingmar in studio with me what's up crack
man hey you doing and to honor Warren we
are each gonna put on some mustaches and
we would really appreciate if during
this call you put your finger over your
upper lip to simulate a mustache and
honor of war and getting healthy hello
Craig's wife and we yeah we have fake
mustaches on oh and and left goes got
like a very old timey Western yeah I
chose Wild West oh wow
if I had why I'd have one of those 1970
pornstar moustache nice I definitely
thought you were gonna say vaudeville
but sure all right so I hear you have
done a lot of looking at this card let's
start off here do you like the card wow
there's the last four games on the card
are really the the standout games that's
for sure
all right so let's start there which of
those popped out to you right away and
have you bet any already yes I I
actually Tennessee over Jacksonville
actually at the last fifth game to count
the money in that game Tennessee over
Jacksonville
you know Jacksonville is a team that the
sharp guys have lost more money on that
any other team this year it's just every
week the Sharps are going to the well
and getting their hit their their their
ass has its own planning yes well
Jacksonville and I'll tell you I watched
a Tennessee Casey game
China has kind of held looked fantastic
in that game now granted that was like a
big game to them was probably bigger
Game of the Year I really like I'm done
with Jacksonville so Tennessee over
Jacksonville this week is one game that
I'm on yeah Lauren Lauren loved that
game too just from like a his models
Tennessee kept popping up whether you
waited it the last month or the entire
year okay so that's kind of an alignment
where you want to go next yeah that's
one looking at some really good games at
the end of the week here the Eagles I
know that's like your your old hometown
right so the yeah listen there are
another team that I just can't do
nothing with but not are against them I
think this is such an important game for
them it might even be their season here
this is such a a really big game for
them sitting at five and five I like the
Eagles over over Seattle Seattle it's
got all the early money feel let's face
it the rating - they're good what
everyone thinks you know they're they're
a good team - so I get crack to that you
just said early money in burr has been
bringing up today the more popular sites
Seattle I think was 82% by 83% 3%
Baltimore right now is already at 82%
when you see a number that big do you
just go right to the window and bet the
other side I want to be on the bookmaker
side all the time that's what I want to
be on so the books are going to beat
that now of course on the last weekend
when they got their head handed to him
their worst weekend of the year but but
but again I'm not going to be passing
around no collection cups for the
bookmaker so this particular weekend I
hope that the books get the money on
that on a few games and that'll be one
of them there with the I'm gonna go
against the public there and and 82% oh
my god isn't that crazy crazy
whether it's Green Bay San Francisco
whether it's total or whether its side
anything jump out to you there cuz
that's that's gonna be a very fun Sunday
night game at the game of the week I
mean really that's one of it's one of
the games of the week really you know
San Fran I overlook the cards last week
and and really they got what do you want
to land on on 10th as you know and I
think you had the 11 in the end up in
there yes I did so uh yeah no III
honestly
the three and a half and in our pool in
our contest is a good line for the dog
they're taking the three and a half I
think that San Fran is definitely one of
the better teams in the NFL I just like
the hook I think it's going to be a
close game and I do like the dog there
but I'm not going to bet the game
because now the line is three but for
any contest or parlay cards which is a
secret thing I usually never talked
about but parlay cards have three and a
half on them I think it's a hook around
the most pious number in the NFL of
three more threes and more games land
free than any other number so the hook
means a lot to me there I love it I love
that the Niners kickers Robbie Gould if
he doesn't play that half a point could
be so valuable as we've already seen
this rookie kicker miss a monster kicks
this year for the Niners oh yeah oh yeah
and the game right between yes do it
look Dallas New England this is
definitely one of the games of the week
New England coming off that back that
game what Baltimore and now they they
ran into you know they ran a couple
little things going on there and you
know some questions about the health of
the players Dallas I don't think we're
ever gonna find them at six and a half
seven point underdogs so this is a
interesting situation if I was betting
this game I would actually bet buy it to
seven that's the second highest number
in the NFL so you could buy the seven
plus seven minus twenty plus seven minus
a quarter I think it's definitely a
smart thing to do I always recommend
buying on three or seven if the sports
books allow it but anyway yeah this is a
big very big it's big for the network
let's face it this is almost like it
could be a Super Bowl matchup they would
matter of fact the network's would love
for this to be the Super Bowl yes sir oh
man they would love this this will be it
you know top two team it would be a real
windfall for them so hey I got a check
for you yeah sure that's it for you and
I'm also curious how much you do this
this is becoming a cleat Blakeman
podcast
okay cool we are fascinated at the fact
than the last nine games the under has
hit nine times with Clark
this is the same ref is the same reel
that called the illegal hands to the
face on Detroit questionable call he had
a number of other questionable calls so
much so then after this podcast last
week when I talked about cleat Blakeman
I had players in the NFL that I did not
know listen to this podcast tell me oh
that guy has screwed us plenty of times
he is roughing he is roughing Jets
Raiders this Sunday oh man if the number
keeps dropping I don't even care because
I just like yelling cleat do any of your
readers or anything ever give you
information like this and do you value
anything it's actually you know it's
funny we look at umpires in baseball the
strike zone so why not look at referees
and their tendencies it's a fantastic
listen that's why I always say I do it
on shows during the week there's no one
sharper than you on that and you know
that back that is just a great it's a
great we see you bet on peyer's in
baseball a lot oh god you have to the
strike zone there terrible some of them
and some of them are good some of them
are bad you have to know your umpire so
without a doubt so you're more like five
people on planet Earth that doesn't want
robot umpires Colin strike zone's
correct no just like just like these
referees and they're getting worse and
worse you would think with all these
going to New York and goes you know all
these new things Clinton put in place to
make the game more efficient you would
think that it makes for a better game I
actually think it they're they're
embarrassing themselves they're they're
the the laughingstock of social media
every Monday morning I have one last
question
you've seen my bets every week are you
noticing a troubling trend is there
anything that you keep seeing me do that
you're like damn it left go stop doing
that absolutely not look how good you
were doing earlier in the season you're
still doing okay last week I think ran
to everyone you can't keep that to the
NFL you know to hit 55 percent in the
NFL you're doing an unbelievable job you
have an unbelievable season so no I I
like what you're doing I think that you
keep on doing what you're doing and as
the season goes on there's going to be a
little secret here usually I'll use the
bed
headlines and bet those bad lines if
something's three and a half on the card
but now it's six in the you know in a
sports book I'll say ladies a three and
a half when you have to play catch-up we
actually have to take the three and a
half take the bad why do we start doing
that when we start going into Tiger week
13 week 14 so we may start to look at
that should we gonna jump on it now and
just start betting all the bad lines you
know I'm gonna say no I'll look more
deeply to see where we both are in the
pack and I will definitely send you a
text because this is they're paying a
hundred places here so and you know
there's there's the situation where you
try to get yourself in the money and the
only shot you have is to bet the bad
lines and that's a real big secret in
the industry that I'm sure the the
tournament guys that that go around and
torment pros don't don't want out there
but yes what I do is what you do you're
the man dude as always go download the
crack wins app this is the season to get
down with Bill Kraken burger basketball
football there's so many things going on
that casinos can't keep up with it but
you know who can crack can crack wins
love it if you want yeah we could bottle
that up we could sell that that was
great that's a t-shirt great to hear
from you guys all right buddy
I mean talk soon and I just got another
alert from the Bleacher Report app mason
rudolph denies that he said it and said
this is quote a desperate attempt to
mitigate his suspension even going as
far in the statement as saying this is a
lie it was from it appears to be Mason
Rudolph's attorney guess what don't even
need an opinion
I'm just saying facts because I don't
want to talk about this reading the app
alright I hope you guys enjoyed this
show where as Brian Westbrook would say
hey okay I try to give you as much
warrens information as possible as
always you can follow him at on twitter
and sharp football
you could follow me on social media at
Adam left co-anchor people ask me all
the time
what are you gonna get on social I might
get on there soon really yeah I'm
feeling it you can find him in the
YouTube comments that's right I do
respond to people's comments in the
YouTube yes if they message me and they
say how do I message in bur and I say
you can't he's elusive Warren feel
better homies you're the greatest for
Ingmar I know people say dress for the
job you want not the job you have but
that's terrible advice no one likes the
intern who wears a suit to the office
when everyone's wearing casual very good
point on the lef KO a man will holler at
you later
[Music]